it's a very damning report it's um
i know from
my experience in working with victims
and survivors of child sexual
exploitation that
it's a hidden problem and there's a lot
more
um prevalent than um we think it is i
think it's seen as something that we we
did so we did that back with rochdale
and rotherham and the problem sort of
solved now and we're now moving on to
other problems like um child criminal
exploitation which obviously is a really
big problem as well but the report
highlights this very very well and says
effectively um the way that local
authorities and police are gathering
data and the way that they're analyzing
that data means that they're effectively
hiding the problem in plain sight and
merging it with all these other problems
and so nobody really has an idea of how
bad it is other than it has to be worse
than the statistics are telling us
and the report found that they're
reluctant to be labeled as you said the
next rotherham or rochdale so they don't
give the necessary data over
yes or just the way that data is counted
just doesn't mean that the way that
they've set up their systems to count
data means that these sorts of things
aren't counted so um for example in some
of the local authority areas that the
inquiry examined child sexual
exploitation wouldn't be classed as a
separate category and it would be rolled
in with other things like um child
criminal exploitation which is a really
big problem but it's a very different
kind of problem which overlaps with with
child sexual exploitation but they both
need to be recognized for what they are
and they both and potentially have
different solutions and children
involved need need different sets of
support and so that what's happening is
that everybody's collecting their data
in different way analyzing the data in a
different way and sometimes not
collecting it very well at all so the
whole thing is just a chaotic mess
what does it mean when it said that they
failed to keep pace with the changing
nature of this crime
so the inquiry report focuses heavily on
the fact that so much and exploitation
of children
now occurs through the internet um it
referenced a lot particularly in
relation to um boys being um exploited
and things like the dating app grinder
and
things like that as being um ways of
grooming
and sucking children into this
exploitation and effectively that local
authorities and police forces are just
struggling to keep up with the pace of
how the criminals are
using technology to change their methods
of exploitation
so then how do you go about unpicking
this and dealing with this issue
i think we need a complete reset on
child sexual exploitation in this
country i think that um some brilliant
work was done um in the past and coming
out of and the horrors of rochdale and
rotherham it really felt like there was
a few years ago a real renewed energy
both within the government at that time
and certain police forces and local
authorities to tackle this issue and i
feel that that energy is all fizzled
away and we need a complete reset we
need to be completely honest that this
problem hasn't gone away it's not
getting less it's getting
getting worse that it's everywhere and
that we need to actually have a
completely new um strategy at a national
level to tackle child sexual
exploitation and that has to be fed
through into the number of prosecutions
so one of the inquiry recommendations is
about sentencing that um should be an
aggravating factor and added to the
sentencing act and 2020 if somebody's
convicted of offences relating to the
sexual exploitation of children that's
brilliant but we know that so many cases
don't even get to be prosecuted let
alone convicted because we have systemic
issues with the resourcing of our
criminal justice system so the police
force is investigating these crimes and
the cps deciding to prosecute these
crimes just isn't happening at the level
that it should be and so there's no use
just altering sentencing if we can't
even prosecute people for this atrocious
crime in the first place and that needs
to change
okay kim
thank you so much for talking to us
thank you